yeah you want welcome to this video
thing grandmaster molten that's mortally
right mobile tinley 36 yeah this is
something that I want to study but have
not yet gotten around to do so they play
it like this i believe but don't ask me
why i think there is some f5 based thing
going on is that a move let's try it
completely experimental I've seen
something like that in the latest new
inches a year book but I'm not sure that
it was exactly here yeah now if I know
somehow magically if it can put the
bishop on to d5 I would be in very good
shape
i also have g5 does i've seen this in a
game by girl for me yeah he wisely um
prevents that maybe i can play with this
and then g5 and that's that's a really
cool position very unconventional but I
don't know I feel I'm okay here until he
seems to be concerned so maybe I can
activate my cranial on the 9th wolf
queen age five on gt5 he had he had
queen age five that's why I didn't go to
500 we have identical reading sir he's
out for a draw I don't think so I mean I
think I can repeat once I think it's me
the thing is when where do I go if I go
to age 60 place we should see one
probably okay so let's see now of course
i'm not drawing i just want to make my
mind up what to do maybe here I mean the
Queen trade and also actually looks good
that position should be quite okay with
Queens traded okay at school g5
yeah but what is the point of all this
hmm I wonder I wonder if Bishop if a
dozen move just to trade yeah probably
and then I'm ready for G 495 like
justify i am fra on the King side yes g4
like g4 takes 95 this is probably rather
dangerous yeah that I understand it is a
very understandable trading idea yeah I
think taking us correct that point isn't
exactly strong I think at least in most
cases still I would love to have my
bishop on d5 mc5 takes the should be
seven or ten is got c6 maybe this move
have a look at the pawn and like I Scott
the 95 yeah I bet that's oh but then I
completely overlook this idea Queen a
495 and then g3 okay so we know that
between h4 was rubbish it was real real
rubbish
okay so unnecessary was that and I know
that position is suck suck slowly I
think I think I yeah I think it was
quite quite a bit better than
c5 takes look TechSoup takes to take
screen h6 mate that is really really
unfortunate
I can just check the Queen I mean trade
second as wrong you can take down as the
shame level such that was a really good
position for like and now we can win
with whatever wiener for the Queen Queen
h4 was just extremely stupid in this
position I'm I'm just a little then I
totally resumes now it was a matter of
one move really the extremely stupid
move yeah here black asses it's just a
lot better so well gee for my it's not a
lot better but I mean being in trouble
it's just wrong again yes just good
chance i can go there in one move and
just take x86 yeah completely mr.
tinkles today that he can go to e5 was
just very stupid yeah the whole position
here I liked a lot i think here I'm
trying it can also just trade queens of
course am a queen trade with the bishop
pair and the good structures also good
when I want to turn to play for an
attack down n96 is just bad okay yeah I
just have to play g4 so this is a
serious stupid decision like yeah he
probably has to take and now that's not
clear to me taking
oh and this fourth of the drawing
because I can take him enjoy it's really
not this is I think not okay in the
position I should try for more I know
that the engine and gives equal but this
position is still easier for black to
play just much more active and there are
practical ideas here like c5 and the
bishop to be seven animove is a really
terrible one now one now wife solution
becomes grade of course honey yes the
night transfer to e5 with can be okay I
don't need to lose as quickly as I did
when it was a bit too frustrated here
yeah here see fire unfortunately doesn't
work a can even take emphasis well this
is a technique checkmate yeah I should
probably just not played you for and and
try to play a slow stuff but yeah I'm
I'm in terrible shape i don't get the d6
pawn and this is the dominating piece so
not not good and I don't have any chance
to get b7 the bishop activated the
bishop one is six ISM is a somewhat
strange p use it if it gets activated it
will be fantastic for black and don't
don't get them yeah ok guys thanks for
watching